hello everyone and welcome to a very
interesting game from round six of the
2019 Isle of Man check on a swiss
tournament it's a magnus carlsen versus
alexei sure of alexei sure of after he
lost the Fabiana Caruana in round three
after that rollercoaster game one - very
nice games and now he again catches up
to the leaders and he now faces the
world champion so without further
further ado let's just check it out as
it is a as it is a very interesting game
so Carlsen with the white pieces opens
with E for again showing that he's up up
for a for a good fight with E 5 by sheer
of knife to f3 and now Knight to f6 here
goes for the better of defense with D
for my cousin - silence attack Knight
captures on e4 and now Bishop to d3 the
standard idea with d5 and now grabbing
his pawn back with Knight captures on e5
now we have night at least 7 by shear of
Knight to c3 by Carson and now Knight
captures on e5 with D captures on e5 and
also a trade on c3 Knight captures B
captors and already as of move 8 all
Knights are gone from the board with
Bishop to e7 preparing to Castle and
both players Castle now we have castles
castles and f4 michaelson and here not
allowing further expansion she pushes f5
himself where you don't really gain
anything by capturing on poisson and
other than that you've pretty much done
a good job closing in white special pair
so Bishop to e3 causing continuous
development and now we have follow
following basically the same game
Nikita fatigue of had against Wesley so
in the World Cup I think we covered that
game with you go on a very nice game but
in that game Bishop to e6 was played by
Wesley and here c5
is a move that share of choose and it is
a new move so already has a move 11 we
have a completely new game with no
Knights on the board but should back to
e 2 by crossing as you're not waiting
for something like this to happen not at
the moment but you always have to keep
an eye on it so be sure back T to cross
and now once the Raymond over this
Bishop they have three to go for the d5
pawn Bishop to e6 developing also adding
another the
to the e to the d5 pawn and now Bishop
to f3 Queen to d7 just developing
connecting rooks and now a four by
Magnus
we have rook a to d8 and here Queen to e
to getting the Queen away from the D
file and Queen to c7 Queen to c7 with
some very tricky ideas here oh here is
preparing to push g5 at some point and
with the g5 in place wife will not be
able to capture because of Queen
captures on e5 or rather White will be
able to capture but she ro will get a
very interesting game rook F to be one
crossing transfers the rooks over to the
Queen side and now b6 not allowing any
ideas on the Queen side and here as the
B file is now pretty much closed cost
and shifts the rook over to d1 so rook
to d1 and here sheriff couldn't take
this slow maneuvering game any longer
and he decided to play some real chess
and he played the g5 so here you could
you could capture on g5 for example pawn
captures and then you have to calculate
ideas like Queen captures an e5 also f4
is a very sneaky move so now the bishop
no longer goes to the g5 point you can
only then recapture it after that so a
lot of very complicated positions can
happen if if cross and decides to
capture on g5 and you don't want to play
positions like that against Alex a
sheriff especially if he maybe had this
or similar positions at home on the
board so of course and just plays h3 he
prepares he prevents g4 also he doesn't
mind just pawn captures because after
Bishop captures d5 pawn is nicely
protected we have looked at b7 now
preparing to double up rook standard
e-file hopefully push d4 at some point
and the caution does the same look the
d2 and our cousin is preparing rook a to
d1 rook F to d8 and the cross and also
doubles up on the default located e1 to
counter the the d4 threat and g4 now
sorry another g4 g captures on f4
first grabbing upon with Bishop captures
on f4 and now that the bishop no longer
guards the d4 square now here of taking
this opportunity to push d4 and already
you can see that a lot is happening on
the board with all through this idea of
of pushing g5 now you know things are in
motion and Carlson plays Queen to f2
it's a very sneaky idea if for example
now D captures and c3 looks like a very
nice idea but he captures on c3 cousin
had in mind
Queen to g3 trek and after the King
moves rook captures on d7 rook captures
back and now do you see what crossings
idea was I'll give you a couple of
seconds just for you for you to spot it
for those of you who were able to do
that congratulations on finding a
beautiful rook lift and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
rook to d6
and now the point is the king is stuck
here and if you capture the rook well if
you don't capture it then you're just
gonna lose the bishop you the point is
you cannot move this bishop because then
what cousin plays east six he frees up
this diagonal and then the bishop can
claim the e5 square for his Bishop and
that's game over for black so you kinda
have to capture the rook after a bunch
of characters he captures now you don't
really have a good move Bishop to e5 is
coming also your queen is under attack
you could try rook to g7 the try to give
back the piece and trade Queens as the
bishop is covering the queening square
but problem is cousin has Bishop to e5
here and now you don't really have a
good move Queen d7 blocking but now this
crazy maneuver Bishop c6 you cannot
capture because Queen characters with
checkmate so you have to move the Queen
and now another crazy maneuver brush up
to d5 a getting rid of this bishops
control of the d7 square you cannot
allow the Bishop captures here because
if Queen captures again you're getting
checkmated so if pawn captures and now
you just play Bishop captures quit check
Queen captures Queen capture screen
captures and just the 7 and the black
king is too far to stop promotion so
that's what Carson had in mind with this
Queen to f2 move of course sheriff
spotted he plays King tha doesn't allow
this to come with check and King to h1
by Carlson also improving the position
of Ace King as the dark square Bishop is
still on the board you don't want your
King on the on the same diagonal as your
queen if the position opens up Queen to
c8 by sheriff now getting the Queen out
of this diagonal and King to h2 now by
and here the time on the clock is quite
different than what you would expect
it's 52 minutes Carlson and only 11
minutes for Shiro or maybe you've
expected it I don't know what you guys
were expecting but here Shiro abandons
his control of the D file and he plays
rook to G he shifted the attack over to
the Kings side and sort of tries to
trick Carlsen because here you cannot
capture an on d4 or maybe you can
because that's exactly what Crossan did
he played the see capture Sundy for
after she rode recaptured khasinau just
played rook captures on d4 and allowed
this Bishop to c5 move of course sure of
trade once rook captures and cross and
recaptures with the rook he could
capture with the Queen but it's a bit of
a passive idea after rue goes back you
have to go back with the Queen Queen f2
and now for example if the rooks are
traded you have this well you're still
up upon but it's hard to say hard to say
it's a pretty crazy position so here
cross and played a more solid line after
rook captures he played rook captures on
before he allows the Bishop to c5 and
here cross and played c3 with the idea
that the bishop captures cousin just
gets a beautiful upon pawn pawn center
but there was also this Queen to h4 mu
which is really interesting it goes
after the Queen to f6 check so the point
is after Bishop captures on d4 you get
Queen to f6 check rook the g7 and now
Bishop to h6 threatening mate and after
the Queen defends this now you play
Bishop captures and g7 Queen captures
and Queen to d8 check and now you just
pick up this Bishop so Queens you a to
Queen captures on d4 and you get a
similar position white they still up
upon but black is really passive here
you can never move the Queen away from
the Queen and bishops control the d5
square for example if you can get this
Bishop to d5 and capture here if the
Queen comes somewhere like these six
you're gonna start pushing this point
it's a very easy win for what so here it
would be really really tough a really
passive position for black but cross and
decides to go for the like we mentioned
more solid c3 and okay sheriff says yeah
okay
I see what you did there you know pretty
good
stuff but rip capture Sundy foresee
capture Sundy four and now what do you
play here Shira play the Queen to d7 of
course you cannot allow d5 if d5 happens
it's game over
so Queen to d7 walking the D pawn and
here the time situation clock is 15
minutes Crossin and four and a half
minutes for sheriff and here what do you
play cross and decided well you either
have to choose against between h4 h5 and
h6 or Queen to d2 the move cost and
played now again preparing pawn to d5
and you have to be careful on how you
stop it for example rook to d8 does
prevent d5 but it doesn't prevent Bishop
to g5 never just lost you have to move
the rook it's a pretty silly idea and
once you move the rook just d5 and you
win the game the e6 is coming next
you're gonna remain over the bishop here
it's a complete annihilation
so after Queen d2 Bishop to d5 by fear
of and now comes the move course and had
in mind if he didn't have this move I'm
sure he would have gone for the Queen h5
line we discussed but here crossing
plays east six it's a nice pawn
sacrifice he clears the e5 square for
his Bishop we have Queen captures and e6
and now Bishop to e5 with check rook has
the block and now what do you play here
Queen to c3 khasinau wants to get to the
Queen well to the back rank if possible
a big mistake would be something like
Queen to g5 like a threatening checkmate
but you I'm sure you all see why it's a
pretty big mistake even feel free to
pause the video if you don't because
it's a-you know something like this
could happen in your own games so for
those of you who found this
congratulations on punishing white for
such a silly mistake that didn't
actually happen in the game and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show Queen captures on e5 I know we all
saw that D captures and I just become
the Queen and well white will recapture
the bishop but after f4 you're picking
up this pawn and it's it's a completely
winning in game 4 black grabbed the
exchange you're up upon well you will be
up upon there's no way to prevent that
and it's it will be an easy win for
black so after rook g7
across and decides for Queen to c3 and
now we have Bishop characters on f3 and
getting rid of this bishop also there's
the there
there is this threat of just Bishop
characters on d5 once the Queen captures
you will no longer be controlling see it
just queen CA 2 wins the game so she
wrote rate special captures Queen
captures and now what do you play here
the thread is Queen - aah check and it's
not all that easy for example if you try
to unpin white will not go for the rook
White will still go for this Queen - 8
check and after King to f7 now just play
Queen captures on a7 and you're either
winning the rook here or if Queen blocks
you can you're just winning well you
will be up a piece at the end of this
very very nice line but there is one
other move it's a it's a brilliant
brilliant defensive resource so a cross
and is threatening a queen - a trick but
also if the Queen goes back to defend
the back rank you have to give up bf5
points so what else is there it's really
just just a powerful move but again feel
free to pause the video and try to find
this defensive resource shear of had in
this position well I give you a couple
of seconds so for those of you who were
able to see it and find it it's it's
really just uh just a disgusting engine
move so if you spotted it -
congratulations the point is you have to
combine the two ideas how to prevent
this and the Queen captures if the Queen
moves well just give up a different
point it's h5 and this this really saves
black a lot of trouble for example Queen
captures on h5 would check King to g8
now you've on pinned White has to
capture the rook now Bishop captures
King captures and now you black has some
ideas of 26 Czech followed by Queen
captures here also the the a four point
is a bit weak black also has some plans
of a six fold by b5 to create a passed
pawn on the Queen side so here for
example if Queen d1 just keeping around
this pawn here you play a6 you're gonna
push b5 create a pass pawn here and you
have some very nice counter attacking
chances so this was really a sneaky idea
that did not happen over the border of
played the Queen to e8 he decided to
give up this pawn but he will claim the
a4 pawn for himself so cousin capture
that Queen captures and now King to g8
you cannot allow any checks while while
the the rook is pinned and now Carlson
has to decide
whether he wants to play Queen to f6 or
just capture it right away if Queen f6
you have to move rook rook here and now
okay you do get the H square king of
seven Queen captures here but then after
King to e6 you grabbed another pawn now
it's four points against two but black
still has a roof so white is better here
there's no doubt about that but it just
seems like a more complicated position
than the one cross and chooses he plays
the Bishop captures in g7 just go
straight into the Queen and pawn in game
being up a pawn so queen king captures
on g7 Queen to g5 check by Carson King
f8 and now Queen to f4 with check with
King D 7 if if you block with the Queen
also possible then for example the Queen
f7 then just king g3 of course cross and
once here of the capture so he can
improve the position of his King and
it's still a king upon him wherever you
were down upon would be very hard for
black to play this so he tried came to
e7
but now cousin plays Queen to b4 check
King f8 and he just captures the h7 pawn
and Shiro decides to capture an a4 Queen
captures on a4 and with this move we
reach move 40 both of them reach time
control they are given additional time
and Carson is still up upon but on the
other hand europe has two connected
passports on the Queen side Carson goes
for Queen to f5 check with King to g7
Queen to e5 check King to f7 and here
cross and played h4 and well here
sheriff started thinking and after
thinking for I believe some 17 minutes
it was in this position that Alexei
Shiro
resigned the game you might think that
it's a bit of a premature resignation
but in this top level chess it's it's
not because hero knows that this is
winning and it's winning if white plays
the best moves and he respects cross and
to think that he will play the best
moves and III think that Shiro just
wasn't he wasn't satisfied the way he
played here and he wasn't able to create
something but it's it's hard to create
something against Carson I think Carson
was actually very happy when she replied
g5 I think cousin just thought to
himself Oh
it's not me who will be trying this game
you try and then I'll just play oh you
know just try and play best moves and
see what happens so I think Carlson
doesn't mind playing positions where
he's the one who's under attack but and
he doesn't get shaken psychologically
easily which is something that you know
the sheriff can really achieve you know
in other players so here we could we
played out a bit more for example if
Queen c6 you bring the Queen back into
the game
d5 is coming Queen d7 now h5 and it will
be very hard to stop both of them so I
think the Norwegian supercomputer says I
said like it was a total domination for
white like a mate in 100 moves saying
that even if black plays whatever it's
still going to be just winning and like
I said sheriff doesn't doesn't want to
play this out and maybe hope Magnus will
blunder or try you know he will try
tomorrow in a new game where he will
then try to create something else as he
always does yeah a very nice one by
Carlsen and we're not gonna show the
standings or mention the standings just
yet as I'm about to show another game
from round 6 but the link in the
description below takes you to the
standings so feel free to check them out
for yourselves if you are if you just
want to do it now so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank how much mizuchi before you
contribute a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
video serum thank you for watching and I
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice tournament checking up in your
wonderful suggestions and of course
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day